problem truly is weak men
because what happens is he comes in
and he's he's larping i'll use the word
again he's telling her all this so he
can sleep with her all these things and
then when she what really upsets her is
she realize this dude lied to me
he's not this great man he says he is
then she starts looking the other
direction we hate weak men yeah
absolutely as you should biologically
you should because look at every other
species right every other
species the strong
male i'm not gonna say the the word but
the strong male is the one that's doing
all the mating yeah and why would that
be because the species wants the best
exactly reproductive
i wholeheartedly quality in children but
that's why i have a huge problem with
outfits like fresh and fit
because you're coming after women and
you're teaching men how to mac and
actually you're not teaching them how to
be
really what they say is alphas you're
not you're just teaching them
but no one watches that [ __ ] they do
teach that i think i think that's just
just to speak up for those guys they
they absolutely do i mean and there's
this whole thing now in this community
in this space online where people are
talking about money muscles game and
frame you know and it really is about
covering all the bases and i mean fresh
and fit they've got their money podcast
i mean myron was a fitness is a fitness
guy i feel special so they they do they
do cover and they also
and then they add in the mac in and what
is
you're literally just going around
presenting yourself as something that
you're not and then painting women to be
the villains of the piece so you're
saying like they're presenting
themselves as like alphas and they're
not no no but they don't they don't say
that they're alphas like they've never
said that in any show well they are
right they do purport to try and teach
people how to be better at well they do
so so i mean that's that's what they
teach it's like a men's self-improvement
show so they teach men how to make more
money they teach men how to get in
better shape they they teach men how to
talk to women because as much as like we
went want to [ __ ] on game and stuff like
i love me a smooth talker like
like i love me like i'm not even gonna
cap and and so you know at least they're
helping men become better men and become
the men we want to be with i don't think
i don't believe that anybody
with any credibility in the in that
space is teaching guys to be something
they're not i think if you are i think
that then there is a problem with you as
a coach and a content creator i think
what most people are saying myself
included but also as you know the fresh
and fit guys and everybody really is
saying be the best man that you can be
um but also present yourself in the best
way possible and that and that does
involve some degree you also have to
understand real up really quickly to
inject interject here is that
the the dating
marketplace that we are currently in in
2022 right unfortunately
you can be
the best product in the world
you could say say joe from
somewhere in the middle of england okay
right he is what was that wigan in wigan
cool he's now he's in wigan joey wigan
is a multi-millionaire he it would be a
fantastic father he's got the best
values in the world he will
you know look after you
like build a great future for you
but
he is
a terrible smooth talker
he's the best product but his marketing
is [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and right now we
live in a world a day and age where the
marketing is basically everything
your photos how you present yourself
your social media that is the marketing
in today's day and age and dating
unfortunately for men especially
unfortunately for men
because if you suck at marketing
you ain't getting any attention you get
no chances you could be the best product
but if you're marketing your [ __ ] you're
done can i please speak into them
it could be someone that has good
marketing and have great pictures and
show all this great life
but then when you go and meet them they
could be the practice guy with no no but
they could they could be a guy with no
boundaries with like no game no nothing
totally true and that's that's the
actual problem walter and myron
walter and myron and fresh and fit
walter and meyer are absolute [ __ ]
heroes
i'll tell you why okay of course they
help with muscle of course they help
with money and helping understand money
but the number one thing that they do
is help young men understand female
nature and both men and women need to
thank myron and walt for exposing that
amen now it might not be at the same
polarity of a miami ho
but if a man understands female names
miami lady
no those girls are hugs bro
so but if a man understands this female
nature truly
the problem
in addition to mar in addition to mario
keying is actually
management project management
you need to understand female
female nature
if you understand female nature you are
more likely substantially more likely to
keep your woman happy because when she
[ __ ] texts you and she doesn't know why
and you crack back and she's like god
that was [ __ ] sexy i'll never leave
this man
i'm telling you
myron and walt are [ __ ] heroes
yeah you're sort of like because i just
don't agree with this this this
that podcast i don't fundamentally what
is it specifically that you don't agree
with just like just the way they talk
about women the way this is the thing
it's just like if i'm going to learn
from a man like how
um they think or how um do you know what
i mean like just just learn in general
just from a man's point of view
i i
like
the way that they
dehumanize women the the terms that they
use like what issues
exactly things like hoes and all of that
kind of stuff and i just think it's like
what's all that kind of stuff though
sorry i hear you say hoes but what's all
that other kind of stuff
um they kind of don't look like do you
do you think that they think about women
nicely do you feel that women speak on
their show they kind of like can be
derogatory sometimes nine out of 10
women on that show have an only fans
account where they sell nudes for money
okay but that doesn't mean that they
should be talked to anyhow or like but
it shows the type of character that that
girl is because she takes the easy way
out does that mean you should talk to
talk but here's but here's the thing
here's the thing i will agree with you
wait i will agree with you that i do
think they're rude at times like i'm a
polite person so sometimes like they can
be rude but like they're helping men and
that's that's their end goal
i just could i just take issue
i mean i've been on the show for a
couple of times and uh i mean
justin's been on and sterling been on it
more times than me but i've been on a
couple of times i've known myron for a
few years and and like when you're there
i mean i i sort of fundamentally
disagree that they're disrespectful to
the women because actually they they
will you they will always give everyone
an opportunity to come in yes you know
um and if a male guest actually is is
talking too much something they'll calm
them down say no let her come in and you
and even when you see them before the
program they're interacting with the
women and everything it's very very
respectful there's no sort of you know
that that because they i mean apart from
anything else they know that you know
these women are kind of make what part
of what's making the show so popular but
they i i would fundamentally disagree
that they are in any way being sort of
like deliberately derogatory towards the
women i mean what's being displayed may
appear derogatory but that's often
because of the way the women are
behaving yeah that's that's the other
thing oh no
well i think what you're mixing up is
the the message
versus the entertainment part
they've seen myron tell a girl
hey do you understand like in a way that
he kind of knows that she might piss
back at him yeah and then he can boot
her but that's the entertainment side of
that show yeah that's what i don't know
i just said yeah that's what you don't
like the reason
it's the reason you're watching it right
yeah
the reason most people are watching it
that is true
that's it's the jerry springer of our
age
this show
but that is the unfortunately that's
human nature
look at why was jerry springer so
popular speaking to the mic sorry i'm so
sorry but just a couple of things just
like you know um it's not necessarily
human nature because the you know as
well all in podcasts and stuff like it
sits on youtube so if you watch
something then you're usually going to
be served something again so where is
normally in real life if you don't like
a conversation you can just walk away
but you know i mean on youtube it will
just continue to be serving people i
don't i don't agree with that do people
walk away from like i see people sitting
there and arguing for hours
in person i don't think they walk away i
think yeah they do i mean yeah i don't
think people get the first fights
this fights would not exist if people
walked away from conversation
my point is just that you know it's not
it's it's it's kind of like an unnatural
way to con consume things like that and
i just think that
i just have a real issue with it and so
where i'm making a face is because it's
my genuine reaction that it makes me
uncomfortable because i feel that they
do a lot of damage to their audience
those women can give as good as they get
as well right i mean some of those women
are like real you know the thing is it's
more about the audience right yeah the
people that are watching it and if they
go out into the world and then speak to
women like that as well or think it's
okay or don't understand like okay we
can understand maybe because we're in it
and we're exposed and all that kind of
stuff but the average person watching it
they don't necessarily understand that
it's just dramatization they don't get
that but there's a lot of that is wrong
and i think it's irresponsible to
continuously perpetuate that kind of
message but what are they what are they
they're not telling them how to like i
don't know what what have they
specifically said where they tell
abandoned like call women hoes or call
women there no but they don't have to do
that what it is is about
just subtly repeatedly putting in
certain messages into their content or
talking to women in a certain way and
repeating that process over and over
again where it becomes the mourn so
therefore you don't have to say that
adverse statement you can just suffer
but that's you reading between the lines
though that's that's you like taking how
yeah like you can't say they didn't say
it but this is what they're saying but
but couldn't you say the same about like
you know hip-hop music and all that
stuff i mean isn't it just like what are
you saying so well that that kind of
terminology was used a lot particularly
like 90s like rap and all that kind of
stuff i mean it's not right eva
yeah but at the same time if you walk in
a club tonight yeah
women everywhere are dancing and shaking
their ass to [ __ ] these hoes i'm
cheating on this [ __ ] and it's cool
when it's little wayne saying that
totally true they're they're super about
they love it this is my [ __ ] blah blah
blah and then but then when it happens
and that's the culture that fresh and
fit yeah it's really much very much
tapped into is that you know
american rap culture sort of street kind
of right
i have a question for you have you ever
really delved into fresh content do you
watch it to a point where you could say
i understood their channel i've watched
their content because
what um some of the guests were saying
were
you're only seeing their content from
the viral clips and the viral clips of
the entertainment and that's the stuff
that
would be dean and then but the thing is
disagreeable i i hear what you're saying
and this this argument often comes up
but then the thing is it's just like
well if everybody's not watching do you
know what i mean like if everyone's
watching everyone's full content then
cool then we have then we're on an equal
step you have context that's not that's
not the same thing and it's just like
you get these
headline
type stats and things like that that are
used to make points but i have to do a
whole thesis on this to make a point no
it's not a full thesis it's like okay i
i just understand a lot where they're
coming i agree like sometimes they're
they're a bit rude for me like i'm kind
of i understand where you're coming from
but it's just
when you're running a show
a lot of times like there are times
where i'm i'm very rude to a guest and i
cut them off but it's only because
they've interrupted me ten times
so i'm so unreasonable yeah
and
and so and so and as a as a show host
like it you you're very disrespected
because you put on all this time into
paying the producers you you put all
this time into getting the guests you
put all this time and energy and effort
just to have a guest that keeps
interrupting you and so by the 10th time
you're like [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up like
that's what most people do and a lot of
times like when their clips go viral
like and i i can't remember i wish i
could quote it off the top of my head
but i can't but the one like rapper that
came in that they kicked out that like
went super viral yeah it was because
like he told them like 10 times to stop
talking and then she like she wouldn't
do it and she showed him coaches
yeah and she showed up late like the
these guys are pretty big yes for me we
were there yeah
yeah these guys were pretty big guests
for my channel they showed up on time
and like it's just
you know and it's just like it's like a
level of respect and you don't always
see the context of the room and i think
that's that's something that most people
don't understand about you know martin
and walter fresh and fit right they're
personal friends of ours we love them to
death
and they have like their hearts are in
the right place yeah they really really
want to tell both men and women i can
tell you this as a man who knows them
personally all right but
again
to reiterate your point that is
like
if you
people have so much entitlement in
today's day and age they really do like
oh i got invited on fresh podcast oh
cool i'm gonna rock up late drink all
their alcohol
be have my social medias blown up by
their
a million subscriber audience have all
my only fans account blown up by their
million subscriber audience which does
happen we know it happens right and
they're still
gonna
talk speak out of line be disrespectful
to myron because he said something they
don't agree with they're gonna be really
rude to him and try to talk over the top
of him right not obey the house rules
like our producer here kind of laid down
before one more thing right
it comes from this place of entitlement
it's a real lack of respect